[Music]
robert spencer here for g
hot watch a program of the david
horowitz freedom center and for the
center for security policy
pope francis recently met in the vatican
with dr muhammad
bin abdul karim al-issa the secretary
general of the muslim world league
a group that has been linked to the
financing of jihad terror
during the meeting al-issa thanked the
pope for his fair positions
on what he called the false claims that
link extremism and violence
to islam in other words alyssa was
thanking the pope for dissembling
about the motivating ideology of jihad
terror which his
group the muslim world league has been
accused of financing
and for defaming other religions in an
effort to whitewash islam
now mind you i don't object to the
pope's meeting this man after all
jesus was a friend of tax collectors and
sinners but the meeting appears to have
been a pointless feel-good session
probably featuring some sly dawah from
al-issa
according to breitbart news the two men
reportedly exchanged views on a number
of issues of common interest
including peace and global harmony and
discussed cooperation on issues of
peaceful coexistence and the spread
of love the spread of love yes that's
what the muslim world league is all
about
nor was this the first time that a
muslim leader has thanked the pope for
being so very useful
last july ahmed al-tayeb the grand imam
of cairo's al-azhar
thanked him for his defense of islam
against the accusation of violence and
terrorism
as any other pope of rome in the history
of christianity
ever been heralded as a defender of
islam
of course not but the catholic church
has come a long way
since the days of pope calixtus iii who
vowed in the year 1455 to quote
exalt the true faith and to extirpate
the diabolical sect of the reprobate and
faithless muhammad
in the east if time travel could be
arranged
and pope francis could meet to meet
callixtus iii
callixtus could expect a punch
because francis is not just a defender
of islam but a defender of the sharia
death penalty for blasphemy
after islamic jihadis murdered the
charlie hebdo cartoonists
who had drawn muhammad francis obliquely
justified the murders by saying
that it is true that you must not react
violently but although we are good
friends if an aide says a curse word
against my mother
he can expect a punch it's normal
you can't make a toy out of the
religions of others these people provoke
and then something can happen in freedom
of expression there are limits
so for the pope murdering people for
violating sharia blasphemy
laws is normal and it isn't terrorism
for
christian terrorism he said does not
exist jewish terrorism does not exist
and muslim terrorism does not exist
they do not exist he said that in a
speech last february
he went on there are fundamentalist and
violent individuals in
all peoples and religions and with
intolerant generalizations
they become stronger because they feed
on hate
and xenophobia so you see as far as the
pope is concerned
there is no islamic terrorism but if you
engage in intolerant generalizations you
can
expect a punch the pope like the
organization of islamic
cooperation apparently thinks that the
problem in the world
today is not jihad terror but
non-muslims
talking about jihad terror muslims would
be peaceful
if non-muslims would simply censor
themselves and self-impose
sharia blasphemy restrictions regarding
criticism of islam
for pope francis has no patience with
those who discuss such matters
he says i don't like to talk about
islamic violence
because every day when i read the
newspaper i see violence
he said when he reads the newspaper he
reads about an italian who kills his
fiance or mother-in-law
the pontiff added they are baptized
catholics they are violent catholics
he said if he spoke about islamic
violence then he would have to speak
about
catholic violence as well now
that comparison just made no sense at
all for italian catholics who kill their
fiances or mothers-in-law
we're not acting in according with the
teachings of their religion
while the quran and islamic teaching do
contain
numerous exhortations to violence
but pope francis defender of islam
cannot concern himself with such
minutiae
nor does he appear to be particularly
concerned about the fact
that all his false statements about the
motivating ideology
behind the massive muslim persecution of
christians over the last few years
only enables and abets that persecution
for if that ideology is not identified
and confronted
it will continue to flourish the pope of
rome whom catholics consider to be the
earthly head of the church
should be a defender of christianity not
a defender of islam
the religion that has been at war with
christianity and with judeo-christian
civilization
since its earliest days that any
christian leader would be called a
defender of islam
by anyone casts into vivid relief the
absurdity of our age
and the weakness of the free world the
creeping idolatry of the papacy that is
rampant in today's catholic church
with all too many catholics treating
every word of the pope
as if it were a divine oracle only makes
matters worse
can you imagine any muslim leader ever
being called a defender of christianity
of course not muslim leaders are more
aware than their fond defender in the
vatican
that islam mandates warfare against
unbelievers not defense
of the unbeliever's theological views
pope francis is not only disastrously
wrong-headed about an obvious fact
that is reinforced by everyday's
headlines he is also deceiving
and misleading his people about a matter
of utmost importance
and keeping them ignorant and complacent
about a growing and advancing threat
i'm robert spencer